hey there everyone I'm Walter Binet
dziak I'm Heather Ruth and I am I out of
Abe and this is top five last week we
covered the top five best David Tennant
episodes it's finally time for Matt
Smith because bowties are cool mm-hmm I
agree and glasses are cool well yeah and
fish fingers and custard are cool fezzes
are cool
no no not everything is cool okay if
everything if you keep arguing like this
we're not gonna do any more Doctor Who
top 5s all right Matt Smith portrayed
the 11th doctor over three seasons and
seven specials the 50th anniversary of
the show occurred during Smith's run to
celebrate the occasion there was a
special that aired called the day of the
doctor it featured the return of Tennant
as well as appearances by future doctor
Peter Capaldi and fourth doctor Tom
Baker John Hurt also played the role of
the war doctor since this was a special
episode and involved a great number of
different doctors it was not included in
our countdown
though it is a must-see for any who fan
during the eleventh Doctor's tenure we
had some wonderful companions and great
returns of classic monsters like the
weeping angels Daleks Cybermen and the
silence
what's the silence wait till we get to
the countdown and you'll find out these
are the top 5 best eleventh Doctor
episodes number five
day of the moon doctor who has many
interesting and kind of scary villains
but my personal favorites are the
silence the silence are a group of
aliens that have been on earth since
humans invented the wheel anyone who
sees them immediately forgets about them
the moment they turn away they can also
use a kind of hypnotic suggestion to
make people do what they want in the
episode the doctor and his friends are
in America in the year 1969 when they
discover that the world is overrun with
the silence they try to combat the
effects of the silence by making tick
marks on their bodies to count how many
there are as well as use a recording
device in their hands to leave messages
to themselves about the aliens
eventually the doctor teams up with a
member of the FBI to take the silence
down and a plan that involves the moon
landing there are many wonderful moments
that show off the acting chops of the
cast you can always hear me doctor
always wherever she is and she always
knows that I am coming for her do you
understand me always it's also downright
creepy at times at least to me
this episode is also a great period
piece I loved their portrayal of
President Nixon it was just the right
amount of caricature and a real
character on behalf of the American
people I thank you number for Crimson
horror in the suspiciously perfect town
of sweetville people are turning up dead
and red this episode written by Mark
Gatiss refers to these mysterious
casualties as the Crimson horror when a
man comes to investigate the untimely
death of his brother a photo of the
doctor shows up suggesting he's in
mortal peril and that the factory town
is not what it seems as we search for
the fate of the doctor we follow the
Sherlock Holmes ask investigations of
Madame vastra a lizard woman from the
dawn of time and her wife Jenny and
their Sontaran cohort Strax
unfortunately they are trailing the
previous investigations of the doctor
and Clara whose whereabouts are unknown
after a waxy preservation process doctor
mrs. Smith oh yes you do very nicely Oh
grand selection and I accompany more
chovka we love their I'll argue this
episode is one of the better examples of
why the doctor is better in a team
rather than wandering across time and
space alone this Victorian story
features amazing costumes including my
favorite a historical look from Jenny
which makes no sense but I don't even
care cuz she's such a badass the botched
red crimson victims and it's trial
testing brings up an interesting
rebuttal against the old saying blood is
thicker than water
number three
the 11th hour this is the episode that
introduces us to Matt Smith's doctor and
I was hooked from the start the episode
begins with the doctor and the TARDIS
plummeting through England before crash
landing on the lawn of a young girl
Amelia pond Amelia has a cracking time
and space in her wall through which a
mysterious voice can be heard saying
this nation has escaped the doctor heads
back to the TARDIS to fix the crack and
tells Amelia to wait five minutes he
then returns 12 years later to find a
grown-up Amelia who now goes by Amy the
crack is still there though and Amy and
the doctor must find the mysterious
prisoner zero before the prison guards
destroy the whole planet this episode is
a wonderful introduction to not only
Smith's interpretation of the doctor but
also the series as a whole there's a lot
of exposition reoccurring Tech and
time-travel basics explained in an
easy-to-understand way plus we are
introduced to the doctor's companion Amy
right away the episode gives audiences a
great feel for the dynamic that the two
of them will have and builds throughout
the seasons many of Smith's trademark
phrases and characteristics are well
established making him an immediately
likeable character including the bowtie
that's cool bowties are cool
[Music]
it's accessible and fun for all check it
out
even if you're new to whoo number two
asylum of the Daleks the Daleks are the
sworn enemies of the Time Lords so what
would make them kidnap the doctor to
help
[Music]
this is you for centuries the Daleks
have been putting all the broken and
insane of their kind in asylum the
asylum is protected by an impenetrable
shield however a ship called the Alaska
has crashed onto the planet and now a
mysterious transmission is coming from
the heart of the asylum if something can
get in that means that there may be a
way for the inmates to escape and no one
would be able to stop a fleet of insane
Dalek not even the Daleks themselves
none of the Dalek are brave enough to go
down to the asylum
so they capture the doctor Amy and Rory
to go do the dirty work there are many
interesting conflicts that are also a
part of the episode Amy and Rory are in
the middle of relationship issues and
have some really heart-wrenching scenes
I kicked you out I gave you up
the main conflict revolves around a
woman Oswin Oswald who was on the alaska
throughout the course of the episode it
is revealed that she has been
transformed into a Dalek the doctor
helps her come to this realization and
she struggles was whether she is truly a
Dalek or human I am lost when Oswald and
I fought the Daleks and I and baby
Osmond is played by Janna Coleman who
later becomes the doctors companion but
as Clara not Osmond its swibble II
wobbly timey wimey stuff she does a
wonderful job playing the character and
really helps elevate the episode
[Music]
and the number-one facts eleventh Doctor
episode is Vincent and the doctor have
you ever looked at Van Gogh's paintings
and thought how could this man have ever
been considered a failure during his
lifetime well you're certainly not alone
written by Richard Curtis this story
starts at the van Gogh exhibit at the
Musee d'Orsay in current de Paris where
the doctor notices a horrid face in one
of his paintings travelling back to the
time when van Gogh painted the piece the
doctor and Amy befriend the unsuspecting
artist
unfortunately they run into the terrible
creature faster than they expect and to
make matters worse it's invisible to all
except Vincent fortunately the doctor
has a mirror gadget that's able to
identify the monster and the unlikely
trio band together to defeat the unseen
Beast this episode takes place after a
certain spoiler containing incidents so
Rory is not coming along for the ride
but Amy and Vincent make a fast
connection over mutual ginge and sadness
Amy happens to be my favorite companion
and I enjoy the historical episodes
where it feels like you're learning in a
fun way
casting for Vincent is incredibly
spot-on and from costumes to set
dressing this episode really feels like
you stepped out of the TARDIS and into
1890s France there are references to the
real van Gogh paintings and then some
places where they took a little creative
license making it an enjoyable watch for
all those post-impressionist fans or art
history buffs spoilers ahead my favorite
moment in this episode is when the
doctor and Amy take Vincent back to
modern-day Paris to hear the museum
curator speak kindly of the incredible
magic of Van Gogh's work it will never
stop making me sob immediately the story
beautifully touches on mental health in
the tragic real life struggles Vincent
faced sometimes the monsters in her head
are harder to face than the ones right
in front of us good things
donal was softened the bad things but
vice versa the bad things don't
necessarily spoil the good things will
make them unimportant we want to hear
what you guys think what's your favorite
eleventh Doctor episode what do you want
to see us cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know to keep in touch
you could like my Facebook page or
follow along on Twitter and you can find
me on Facebook Twitter Instagram or you
can subscribe to my animated movie
review series multiplex 10 here and you
can find me on Twitter Instagram or
Twitter I stream on Wednesday nights
well catch you right back here next week
with a brand new episode of top 5 as we
kick off October top 5 2018
[Music]
[Applause]
you
Walter what is going on with you right
now are you okay you're talking about
just wrapped up the show uh here look
what what yeah
you